hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of my youtube viewers Christian hey
Christian thanks to the question is 16
years old he has a t-shirt company that
he wants to launch and it's not quite
sure how to do it and wanted my advice
on kind of how to get started should he
had a website etc so Christian to answer
your question what I would do I try to
make sure I start without spending a lot
of money and it's easy to spend money
right anybody can go out and spend money
on any business idea if it gave you a
million bucks i'm sure you can find a
million different ways to go and spend
it but as an entrepreneur it's not about
how much resources you have is more
about how resourceful you can be so i
would try not to spend money until i'm
making money and that's kind of a one of
the golden rules of entrepreneurship at
least for me is not to spend money until
i'm making money so don't go out and
spend a lot of money on a really
expensive website or create tons of
inventory which a lot of entrepreneurs
will do especially in your kind of
business so they'll create tons of
inventory and then it's sitting in your
garage and you can't sell it and you've
wasted all your money so I'd launch a
simple website with some designs put
them up and try to start selling just
the designs that you have so don't go
out and you know Creek huge inventory
and actually have physical product you
can print on demand to print really
limited quantities so you're not
spending a lot of money and you start
bumping up interest in your product so
you have your simple website won't and
start marketing it start talking to
people who are in your industries are
talking to people who are in your age
group you think might be interested in
buying your teacher I try to create
guest posts with bloggers who are you
know in the design field or might have
potential customers for you and just
start spreading the word get some
feedback to see if people like your
designs if they have other ideas for how
the designs could be better and you know
your initial few designs may not be the
ones that make you rich right there may
be the ones that come later down the
road so you don't want to blow all your
money on those first two designs say oh
this isn't going to work and then shut
down your company all right so try to
get the feedback try to start building
up cementum online and offline with your
peer groups people who
and potentially influence some buyers
for you get their feedback Orleans in
design and as sales start coming in you
may not be making a lot per sale because
you're printing on demand your printing
really limited quantity so the profit
margins aren't great but you're also not
carrying huge inventory and when you see
that these products are certain to sell
then you're able to maybe make slightly
bigger orders invest a little bit more
on your business because you have money
coming in so really really really try
not to spend money until you have money
coming into your business take the
feedback from your customers and use
that to continue to grow hopefully that
helps Christian thank you for watching a
YouTube videos for those of you who are
watching I'd love to see the thumbs up
if you liked the video please give it a
thumbs up below and if you have a
question or if you have any other
thoughts for Christian some advice for
him feel free to leave a comment under
the video I usually try to respond to as
many of those as I can so thank you and
stay tuned for next episode
you